Olá se você sofre com sintomas de
refluxo ácido gastrite ou até úlceras
preste muita atenção nesse vídeo você
sabe o quanto sintomas como dor de
estômago queimação estufamento perda de
apetite enjoos podem ser incômodos e
debilitantes Mas não se preocupe porque
esse vídeo é especialmente para você
hoje eu vou compartilhar um suplemento
que tem mostrado resultados bem
interessantes da minha prática médica
especialmente do cust o zinco carnosina
fique comigo para descobrir como ele
pode transformar sua saúde
gastrointestinal e trazer a Lívio para
esses sintomas tão desagradáveis antes
de falar sobre o suplemento é importante
lembrar que muitas pessoas com gastrite
refluxo são frequentemente medicadas com
antiácidos ou inibidores de bombas de
próton os famosos
prazois Esses medicamentos podem ajudar
a curto prazo mas os sintomas geralmente
voltam poucas horas depois de serem
tomados Às vezes você pode utilizá-los
por um curto período como dois ou TRS
meses e depois eles param de funcionar
isso já aconteceu com você além disso
esse tipo de medicamento não é indicado
para uso prolongado porque pode causar
deficiência de vitaminas importantes
como é o caso da vitamina B12 E o pior é
que Esses medicamentos não resolv a raiz
do problema eles são apenas sintomáticos
servem apenas para apagar o incêndio e
nem para todo mundo eles funcionam bem
por isso eu decidi compartilhar com
vocês o zinco carnosina agora você já
ouviu falar do zinco mas o que tem de
interessante diferente desse tal de
zinco carnosina bem esse suplemento é
uma combinação do mineral zinco que você
já conhece muito bem com dipeptídeo
chamado elic carnosina elic carnosina é
composta pelos aminoácidos Bet lanina e
istidina está muito concentrada nos
tecidos musculares cerebrais Mas por que
se utiliza o zinco junto com carnosina
aqui entra a parte interessante a
carnosina tem um poder de ajudar o seu
corpo a absorver melhor o zinco dos
Suplementos entregando zinco aos tecidos
musculares de uma maneira mais lenta
estendida e eficiente Então ela ajuda os
tecidos a se curarem e se regenerarem
Então esse composto é único criado
principalmente para proteger e curar a
mucosa gástrica a mucosa do seu estômago
pessoal essa combinação tem se mostrado
eficaz em promover a integridade e a
função da barreira mucosa do estômago e
do intestino quando você ingere a
combinação de zinco com carnosina ela se
fixa na mucosa gástrica fornecendo
proteção e facilitando a reparação dos
tecidos lesionados essa combinação
possui propriedades antiinflamatórias e
também propriedades antioxidantes assim
ela ajuda a reduzir a inflamação e pode
até promover a cicatrização de úlceras
além disso a combinação do zinco com o
dipeptídeo carnosina ajuda na regulação
da produção do ácido estomacal O que é
muito importante para controlar os
sintomas Muitas vezes os sintomas da
gastrite do refluxo podem ser causados
por falta de Aço não excesso falta de
ácio no estômago e nesse caso o zinco
com a carnosina vai atuar em ambas as
situações tanto na falta quanto no
excesso de ácido para você entender
melhor essa questão da falta ou do
excesso de acido no estômago eu tenho um
vídeo bem interessante sobre isso ele é
recente eu vou deixar o link desse
material aqui na descrição A gastrite
que é uma inflamação da mucosa do
estômago e as úlceras gástricas podem
ser condições bem chatas de ser tratadas
e também bem debilitantes então Nesse
contexto o Zin carnosina tem mostrado
eficácia no tratamento dessas condições
Especialmente quando Associados a
infecção por H piló helicobacter piló
que aquela bactéria chata danada que
gosta de morar no nosso estômago
causando estragos como gastrite e
úlceras se não for tratada direitinho
então estudos mostram que a combinação
do zcan usina quando utilizado em
conjunto com outras terapias
convencionais ou até com outros
suplementos naturais pode melhorar
bastante a taxa de erradicação Ou seja
você se livrar da bactéria H piló sem
aumentar os efeitos colaterais isso
acontece porque o zinco é um potente
agente antibacteriano ajuda a inibir
diretamente o crescimento da cilore
assim contribui para prevenir e
controlar a gastrite úlceras por outro
lado a carnosina tem uma ação bem
interessante porque ela vai sendo
decomposta e convertida em peróxido
dismutase que é um poderoso antioxidante
que vai reduzir a sua inflamação Então
essa explicação do por a combinação
desencarnou é um dos melhores
suplementos para tratar e promover a
saúde intestinal então em casos de
gastrite úlceras infecções prog pilor e
refluxo ácido usem carnosina pode ser
uma ótima opção ele também bem-vindo
para doenças inflamatórias intestinais
vai AJ ajudar a fortalecer a barreira
intestinal Então essa combinação pode
ser utilizada em caso de
hiperpermeabilidade
intestinal onde a barreira do intestino
delgado foi danificada permitindo a
passagem de várias macromoléculas a
maior parte delas toxinas e também
patógenos ou seja bichos né entrando na
corrente sanguínea Além disso suplemento
pode ser utilizado em conjunto com
outros como é o caso da glutamina que eu
gosto muito para ajudar na recuperação
da mucose intestinal porque é bem
tolerado e pode ser eficaz para tratar a
síndrome intestino irritável o super
crescimento bacteriano testino Delgado
conhecido pela segla cibo e em alguns
casos até para doenças inflamatórias
intestinais autoimunes como é o caso da
doença de crom e também da retocolite
osaa duas doenças muito debilitantes mas
como tomar ess suplementos em carnosina
a dose padrão é geralmente 75 mg do duas
vezes ao dia totalizando 150
MG sem ultrapassar essa dose de área
então é preferível tomar o suplemento
com estômago vazio para maximizar a
absorção e obter um melhor efeito na
parede do estômago no entanto algumas
pessoas podem sentir algum desconforto
ao utilizar o zinco com estômago vazio
então nesses casos você pode tomar com
alimentos para evitar esses desconfortos
Outro ponto importante é que o Zin
carnosina não é como um antiácido que
você toma já sente efeito imediato logo
do primeiro a segundo dia ele precisa de
tempo para penetrar nas células
epiteliais gástricas e promover a
Regeneração e cicatrização então o tempo
para ver um efeito pode variar de pessoa
para pessoa mas geralmente é necessário
pelo menos no mínimo um ou dois meses
para começar a sentir um efeito mais
importante mais significativo portanto
não tenha pressa não espere uma ação
muito rápida vamos falar um pouco dos
efeitos colaterais o zinc carnosina
geralmente é bem tolerado mas algumas
pessoas podem experimentar um
desconforto estomacal náuseas e até
diarreia são casos raros reações
alérgicas como erupções cutâneas também
são raras então se você já tomou zinco
antes e se deu bem com ele é muito
difícil ter esses sintomas no entanto é
importante interromper o uso se você
sentir qualquer sintoma adverso Além
disso essencial que você tome esse
suplemento em carnosina somente com
acompanhamento médico ou nutrológica
para que seu médico ou nutricionista
possa orientar corretamente sobre o
tempo de uso também avaliar a progressão
dos seus sintomas e exames e ver se é
necessário usar em conjunto com outros
tratamentos os suplementos Claro existem
outros suplementos interessantes que
podem ser usados em conjunto com s
carnosina para potencializar os
benefícios a tintura de espinheira santa
a tintura de alecrim o gengibre e o Aloe
Vera são todas as excelentes opções para
proporcionar um conforto mai or a saúde
gástrica Além disso enzimas digestivas
também podem ser necessárias para dar
suporte à digestão e ajudar o sistema
digestório a funcionar de uma maneira
mais eficiente se o seu problema for
falta de acido no estômago Ou seja a
chamada hipocloridria a betaína hcl ou
cloridrato betaína pode ser uma solução
mas lembre-se de que deve ser prescrita
pelo seu médico levando em consideração
as particularidades do seu caso em
resumo carnosina tanto usado isolado
quanto aliado a outros tratamentos e
suplementos pode ser uma excelente
estratégia para tratar gastrite refluxo
e úlceras ou ainda promover a saú de
gastrointestinal de uma forma eficaz e
segura Muito obrigado pela sua atenção
um grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
Você é fera